hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday june 6
2022. are you guys like me how many
[ __ ] buttons do you have to shut off
before the [ __ ] tv's off off off off
menu off off menu
guide off
can i help you with something is there
something you're trying to do
um
anyway i've been watching nba all of
that [ __ ] you guys watching that [ __ ]
the series is all tied up and what
um
i actually had a great
realization in uh
in game two
is that i just don't i just don't give a
[ __ ]
about the pro game
i'm just not into it
i just i am not built
to watch an nba playoff game that my
team is in
win or lose i'm just emotionally
i'm not mature enough i have kids i just
i can't do it so i i
like every [ __ ] year like all going
all the way back to dennis rodman
there's these guys in the league that
deliberately get tangled up with other
players and then they act like they're
trying to get up off the floor is this
sort of semi like hitting the guy in
their head
and then the announcer's always like
well you know let's take a look i don't
see any sort of flagrant
i don't think that was on purpose uh he
was trying to defend himself let's get
the [ __ ] it's like did you not have an
older brother
older brothers know how to do that [ __ ]
they [ __ ] act like they lose their
balance whoa and they land on you and as
they go to get up they push off your
head instead of the floor i mean did you
did
were there no older kids in your
neighborhood this is like classic [ __ ]
and they just
never
[ __ ] call it and i just i i can't i i
can't [ __ ] do it i got kids so i'm
not doing it all right i hope the
celtics went but i am uh
i am not like
there's just something about the nba
that i don't know what it is about the
[ __ ] game
um
other than that i really think that it's
like massaged or whatever
like there was no doubt tonight i'm like
the warriors are going to win tonight
whether they win or not they're going to
win tonight they have to win they can't
be down 0-2 the casual fans going to
shut it off the nba is not gonna have
that and i know this sounds like
conspiracy and i don't think that the
referees gave us the game i thought they
played great but even if they didn't
even if they didn't they were gonna win
tonight and i you cannot convince me
otherwise
i just
i'm not uh
this is the only [ __ ] sport that i am
100
if i had to [ __ ] put my all of my
money
on manipulated or not manipulated this
is the sport that i would 100 percent do
it which is a [ __ ] shame too because
i got to tell you something
as much as the warriors were kicking our
ass in that first game in the first half
i was as a fan of sports was 100 still
enjoying the game because steph curry is
like the greatest
shooter of all time
so
um
you know and i've never been that like
like i never hated derek jeter i just
can't i can't like
i mean i'll tease the guy whatever made
fun of that [ __ ] [ __ ] he used to do
to try to get a
you know a strike to become a ball or
whatever that i did on the red sox thing
but i i
[ __ ] love that guy i hate that he
played for the yankees but like i i
never take it to that level
but um
i don't know just
i don't know what it is about the nba
the fans that [ __ ] douche tonight i
think steph curry hit a three-pointer
and they cut to the crowd and there's
some guy miming shooting a bow and arrow
[Laughter]
we played like the miami heat they cut
they cut to the crowd after miami scored
like you know eight nothing run or
something they cut to the crowd and
there's some kid with this giant stupid
chain on and he's like nodding his head
as fast as he can as he's jumping up and
down like like in no other sport
did the fans act like they just scored
um like nba fans and i don't i don't
think they like that in the upper deck i
just feel like there's a certain level
of douche that i i don't know that you
have to be to sit in a lower bowl at a
[ __ ] nba game
um
anyway but mark jackson was in a rare
form
you know
steph curry wide open for a three and
he'd be like i'll tell you right now
that was just terrible defense
by the boston celtics you cannot leave a
man like steph curry
that wide open if you do that's a very
easy way to go down 1-0
in the nba finals
and then remember robert
[ __ ] griffin iii
is like out by the three-point arc guy's
like [ __ ] 610 or something covering
uh steph curry
and steph curry just pull you know he
gave him a little cushion steph curry
pulls up and he hits it once again mark
jackson you mean you just cannot give a
player like that that amount of space
it's like mark he's the greatest shooter
of all time it doesn't matter this guy's
610 what the [ __ ] is he supposed to do
is he supposed to go out and try to
[ __ ] put his dick on his leg he's
just going to go around him and [ __ ]
lay it up i mean
it's steph curry he's going to get 30.
he just it is what it is if you're the
boston celtics enjoy this victory but
know the series is not over
if you're golden state
learn from your mistakes
and move on to game two
thank you mark
what do the boston celtics need to do
right now execute
um
but i swear to god like that [ __ ]
draymond green i mean how many times can
he accidentally fall on somebody and as
he's trying to get up be kicking them in
the chest or in the head accidentally
like you know it's not like you know
enough to make the guy hurt but just
that [ __ ]
um and then they said
no
they try is he trying to get up i don't
[ __ ]
they grab ja rules kneecap and just pull
did he confuse the ball with his patella
i i don't know i don't understand
it's like am i watching wrestling
um
because these are neutral announcers
that's what i don't like it's like
you're neutral i understand a homer like
when i watch the washington capitals
feed they never think you know wilson
does anything wrong i watch the bruins
feed they don't think our guys ever do i
get that but like this is supposed to be
like a national [ __ ] broadcast
um
i don't know did he you know was
is kicking somebody in the balls a
natural follow-through of his jump shot
i i have no idea
um
if you go into the bathroom
a public bathroom to take a piss and
someone is already in there [ __ ]
hold your breath
take out your dick and execute
i want mark jackson advice in everyday
life
if you're driving down the street and
your cell phone falls between your seat
and your center console
learn from your mistake
and continue driving
thank you mark
that was that was riveting
insight um yeah i think i i've got to be
honest with you i just think with my
temperament and i have kids i just
really think that i'm not a playoff guy
anymore
uh i probably never was i just didn't
have little people that are influenced
by my behavior so
i think what i'm gonna be a regular
season guy
you know
i'm gonna watch game number 43 of an 82
game season
and just sit down hey they win it they
lose it i don't give a [ __ ]
um
you know what i mean you know it's like
to be sitting there
playing candy land with your daughter as
you get one
like eye on the screen trying not to be
like
you know like losing your mind like come
on man play defense and all of this [ __ ]
anyways i know it's gonna it's gonna be
a uh a great series interesting match-up
celtics are really young
golden state um very experienced in all
of that so
i don't know
i'll be honest with you after two games
i don't know which way it's gonna go i
hope the celtics win but i have to be
honest with you
i i am
i think
i think i'm too old to watch
my team in the nba finals i don't think
i can [ __ ] handle it and i love my
kids more than i
need to watch this [ __ ] so i'm gonna
just sort of have it on in the
background as i'm playing connect four
and [ __ ] and i'm gonna dip in
get some [ __ ] nba analysis
you
know and and and you know and then just
go back back in i think that's the way
i'm gonna do it um
because other than that what am i doing
my kids don't understand and i want them
to like sports
um speaking of sports i went to the uh
dodgers mets
but before i before i i uh i move on i i
do
want to say what a [ __ ] once again
what a pleasure it is to watch [ __ ]
steph curry play i mean that guy is
[ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] amazing amazing player
and i'm like mark jackson i'm stating
the obvious but like it was a while ago
i think this guy might be the greatest
shooter of alta he is
just like without a doubt i mean that
guy the second he gets over the half
court line
you know i've never seen the guy five if
he's five feet and i mean
in game one he had the ball at the end
of a quarter and like threw it the
length of the court and i actually
expected it to go in
hey i'm telling you the kid can shoot
um all right dodgers mets
i went to the dodgers game um with a
great buddy of mine
new york guy big mets fan and uh went
down and watched uh
the mets trying to split the series
uh
fun game they really upgraded a lot
there with the uh
the dodgers park that's the last of the
cookie cutter stadiums was always the
best
during the cookie cutting
cookie cutter multi
multi-purpose stadiums with most of them
were like for baseball and football but
the dodgers was just for baseball i
think that that's why theirs came out
the best
but um
as i was driving too i thought i heard
somebody say that the dodgers had a 320
million dollar
whatever
what do they call it salary
i don't know
team salaries let me look at this up but
no they they don't they do have a very
high one but it
for 2022 sorry i'm trying to type and
talk i just said i just put in 30 33
sorry
gone on the dark web now
um the payroll that's what they call mlb
payroll
tracker here we go
and this is what i found out i didn't
i'd listen to these [ __ ]
payrolls by these teams here
no i don't want to [ __ ] subscribe
nobody wants to subscribe
all right um
here we go
the at the top of the list is the new
york mets
260 million 222 thousand one hundred
twenty four dollars
dodgers
bear are behind by 197 dollars and
change
260 million
2
500 oh i'm an idiot 22 000
no
jesus christ bill this is why you sucked
at math
two i'm sorry they're like 197 000
behind him
um one middle relief guy
uh new york yankees coming in third 244
million then the debacle that is the
philadelphia phillies
233 million dollars and here's a
surprise that number five the san diego
padres look at them
throwing their dicks around
217 million dollars that's [ __ ]
tremendous and they have to because the
dodgers are spending 260.
but my boston red sox two
201 million
then the white sox 195
the angels 190 the braves one seven and
nine
it's amazing what the braves do
um the astros 175
give or take a few trash cans there
uh the toronto blue jays 169 then the
cardinals 158 the giants 153
the cubs 148 and the league average is
147 million
and change
um and here's the bottom of the league
really quickly uh number 15 through 30.
uh the rangers the twins the tigers the
rockies milwaukee brewers the nationals
now we're down to 130 million
then 117
is the reds the mariners play 106
million now sub 100 million 100 million
dollars sorry 100 million 100 million
dollars
are
the kansas city royals the inexplicable
tampa bay devil race 87 million dollars
and they're [ __ ] in it every year
arizona diamondbacks 87 miami marlins
well you know them
they're schizophrenic they're up and
down they either spend 200 million or
[ __ ] 81 million the pittsburgh
pirates 69 million
cleveland guardians 68
the oakland athletics 48 million and
then the baltimore orioles
46 million dollars i mean this [ __ ]
players almost making that a year now i
don't think that they make it like two
years right
who's the highest played
highest paid mlb player
uh
max scherzer
makes 43.3 million dollars a year look
at that
do what i called it um anyway
let's go back here uh
yeah so i went to the game had a great
time sat right down on the dugout
seats um
you know i mean they had so much [ __ ]
information on this on this the
scoreboard and now they have those nets
that go all the way down the third base
line which i can't [ __ ] believe it
took them that long to have those things
you know
my whole life growing up i just remember
guys hitting [ __ ] screamers into the
crowd
and somehow people would always get out
of the [ __ ] way
like like the amount of people that
should have [ __ ] died did i remember
somebody uh
uh manny motor killed a kid at a dodgers
game in the 70s and they still didn't
put the nets up
um
no social media no [ __ ] national news
like talking about sports and [ __ ] back
then
so nothing was really done about it but
um i remember couple times going to red
sox games and being near one
and everybody got out of the way and it
hit like an empty
[ __ ] seat one of those plastic seats
and i was just like
you know i've always wanted to catch a
foul ball i think i want to catch a fly
ball
[ __ ] those uh i always remember those
guys on the feet like a line drive
into the crowd you'd see all these
[ __ ] hands go up like
jesus chris the [ __ ] are you thinking
it's a goddamn baseball go to a sporting
good store
buy one and just say you caught it at
the game save your fingers there
um
but anyway i had a great time and i have
to say you know
i think the dodger dog is the best hot
dog
in baseball and i don't even think it's
[ __ ] close
as far as just a hot dog on a bun
that's it none of this extra fufu [ __ ]
that they do in all of these stadiums
now trying to justify
um
all of their uh
accoutrements
parking fees and all of that [ __ ]
uh the red sox sweep the a's
we're now at 500 but the yankees keep
winning so nobody gives a [ __ ]
and uh not nobody gives a [ __ ] it's just
not gonna matter why is it suddenly 9
000 [ __ ] degrees in here um
if you're in the room and you're hot
remove your sweater if you're not keep
doing what you're doing and execute
thank you mark jackson
thank you mark jackson whoo
i am for real
oh it wouldn't be la if there was a
wasn't a helicopter flying over
um
um anyway sorry let me get back to here
it was my son's second birthday this
past week
and um
i made him a birthday cake
and uh made like a smaller cake
it was such a friggin
it was such a crazy week you know just
the stress of uh editing the movie
we had our first screening of it with
friends and families thank god it went
well and people liked the movie i got
some great feedback stuff we're going to
go in and fix
going to address over the next few days
we're going to address the notes
that's where i am in my life right now
i get notes and then i address them
yeah i would love to hang out with you
but i have notes that i need to address
um i'm still having fun though um
anyway
uh my thing is i make a birthday cake
from scratch
for my kids
every birthday every year both of them
it's what i do and every year for some
reason
like
you know i don't know my wife always
like i don't know she always thinks i'm
gonna flip out when i'm making the cake
because i used to flip out
way back in the day when i first started
making the pie crust when i want to
[ __ ] stick my head through a window
um
but i haven't like flipped out in years
but like she anticipates it she warns
other people
that it's going to happen
and i actually most funny is i came home
and my brain was so [ __ ] tired
i [ __ ] up the recipe twice and then i
was just like all right
i started to flip out
and then i was just like all right just
just make it in the morning
that's what i did i just [ __ ]
i didn't even clean up i just left the
disaster
by its you know whatever by itself and
then i just made it the next day and it
ended up coming out great
and uh so my wife was right she's white
she like is right to [ __ ] warn people
it's like bill is baking
you know he's you know he's an emotional
guy but you know like if i was almost
like i was a coach he's an emotional guy
you know he cares
he cares he really loves his players
that's like me he cares he really loves
his kids
and uh he gets upset because he just he
wants things to be done a certain way
is there anything [ __ ] funnier or
sadder than listening to somebody
explain away abusive behavior because
the person they're talking about
is either
you know they're married to them related
to them or that person signs their
checks and like your job is to go out
and explain some [ __ ]
that you do you don't even believe in it
you're just sitting there going like all
right was he a [ __ ] again all
right well i gotta [ __ ] somehow get
him out of this mess and just
you know um
the incident that happened the other day
was uh not something that so-and-so is
proud of or anybody is and um
i know it upset a lot of people
including you in the media but i can
guarantee you that nobody is more upset
than the guy that actually did the stuff
that upset everybody
and uh he's vowed to learn from his
mistakes
and um you know we had a nice talk about
it and um
that's gonna be it we're moving forward
um we're not anticipating another
incident
like this and and and i'm not taking any
questions at this time
that [ __ ] you know just explaining
things
let me explain this away um i'm actually
really proud of myself that i actually
got up and walked away from that game
you know i really am you know
it wasn't gonna change i knew the
warriors were going to win tonight i'm
like they're too good a [ __ ] team
they're not going to go down 02.
this just isn't going to happen so just
[ __ ] just walk away from it
before you get your conspiracy theory
going
and and and all of this [ __ ] and i i
kind of did and uh
i think i need to do that more
because as everyone in my life has told
me i don't
possess the emotional maturity
[Laughter]
and i don't it's [ __ ] true i've been
playing a lot of drums lately
which has been fun um
i had a little bit uh a time off on
friday because uh we were doing the
screening and they had to get everything
all we had to send them a copy and get
it all [ __ ] set up and all of that
[ __ ]
and uh
you know i was nervous about what people
gonna think about you know the the rough
screening dude is [ __ ] brutal because
you don't have if the movie isn't scored
so you're just grabbing free tracks from
the internet right
and as
much as they help they also they just
it's just not the right [ __ ]
yet so and then
i don't know
so
people are watching it with the wrong
music and then you're getting feedback
from that so i'm really confused as far
as like so what do i do with that
if the right music was there would they
still think that
they're in the business so they
understand that the right music isn't
there so they're able to push through
that so i should take the note
i got a lot of questions um
you know what i [ __ ] up the other day
was
i had a double espresso in the morning
right
which is what i do i just do it on days
i'm editing the movie
so it just gets me to plow through
when my body wants a nap in the
afternoon because i'm old
you know you're just drinking espresso
it's like young again
um
but then we had to write some [ __ ] and i
didn't want to be in that soulless
editing bay to rewrite this narrow part
where i had to narrate some [ __ ]
so i said to my writing partner well you
know it's a cigar bar around the corner
let's just [ __ ] go over there
you know have a little cigar and we'll
[ __ ] knock this these jokes out so
that's what we did when i was over there
the guy mentioned that he had
espresso
machine and i got a second double i
don't even know why
i just want to see what it was like to
smoke a cigar and have a double espresso
which is [ __ ] stupid
i get back to that [ __ ] editing room
i was so [ __ ] wired
i was like nervous
like i stood up and i could feel my legs
shaking and i was like i am never
[ __ ] doing that again
never doing that again
i've gotten so into coffee that i could
actually drink a mug of espresso
right but after having two double shots
i'm nev and smoke i'm never [ __ ]
doing that again i didn't like the way
that felt at all
i was uh
i was [ __ ] gagged i've never i've
never done cocaine but i don't know if
if that's what it's like i don't know
why anybody would ever do it
it was like
i felt like a squirrel in a tree and
there was something coming up in that
that was gonna kill me and there was
nothing i could do
it was just final eight seconds of your
life final seven seconds of your life
final six seconds of your life
i don't know made me [ __ ] weird the
rest of the night
like i was chilling with my wife yet
hostile
you know not to her but like the tv
she's like what's going on with you i
was like i had
two double espressos and a cigar and
she's like why the [ __ ] would you do
that i'm like i mean i don't know
it seemed like a good idea
you know i got a book on my bookshelf
i'm looking at right now
to just continue with the add of
everything i do oh listen to that oh
listen to that would you that's an a
star
that's the cops
um
it's a book written by john bonham's
brother mick bonham
and i just see it says bonham
b-o-n-h-a-m
i was looking like bond ham bond is
good in french
ham good ham
i'm not on drugs people i just i don't
know
i don't know i'm just i'm i'm
i got a lot of work this summer that's
what it is i have too much [ __ ] work
that's what it is
but i'm gonna get it done
i'm gonna get it done i'm gonna take one
step
that's what it is i i have too much
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i have too much stress trying to get
this [ __ ] movie right
that the last thing i need to do is
watch my [ __ ] team in the nba finals
i don't need to do that
why would i do that to myself i think
that's why i'm watching the red sox
it's june we're playing 500 ball hey you
win one you lose you know is enough time
if we don't win it's okay
uh speaking of which i believe i'm gonna
be uh
the red sox are playing the angels
tonight
and i believe that they're gonna get me
in the booth again to promote my show at
fenway so uh
if you're a baseball fan or not tune in
i'll try to make you laugh
um
during the game and uh yeah i got i got
to do that tomorrow after i edit the
thing
so my brain might be a little fried so
the chances of me saying something
really stupid are pretty good i got to
be careful uh with that let me uh
read some of the uh the advertising here
if i did it correctly is this it here
yeah okay
uh roman everybody
all right style no matter what you're
wearing confidence starts on the inside
that that's why it's so important for
men to think about their testosterone
health early that's because testosterone
is believed to affect everything from
our libido to our blood health
i can use some [ __ ] testosterone
right now
if your dick is staring at the floor
get roman
if it's standing up and saluting the
flag continue doing what you're doing
but know
that the series is not over
um roman style no matter what you're
able that's because testosterone is
believed to affect everything from our
libido to our blood health thankfully
roman's testosterone support
uh supplements were designed by real
doctors
to make this time it's real doctors
everybody not like the fake doctors on
those other [ __ ] things to make sure
your body is maintaining its greatness
feel confident from the inside out with
roman testosterone is an important part
of a man's body and health but men's
testosterone starts to deplete with age
which is why it's important you support
it early and if your testosterone levels
go up here's my question
do you then start making the same stupid
mistakes you made because of
testosterone in your 20s
roman tea support is meant to help men
maintain their body's natural
testosterone production roman t support
is proprietary is a proprietary
supplement formulated by romans in-house
doctors you can't find this blend
anywhere else roman offers flexible
monthly payments with free two-day
shipping go to getroman.com
r-o-m-a-n
bur today
if approved you'll get 15 off your first
order of roman t support that's
getroman.com getroman.com
and um
oh here's something in my [ __ ]
wheelhouse right now solo stove
are you about to be 54 years old and you
can't emotionally sit still
during an nba final game
do you need to go off and be your loan
why not get a solo stove life's best
moments happen around a roaring fire you
know what's great about a roaring fire
too it also like like drowns out you
complaining
about referees um af and a smokeless
fire pit from solo stove makes your
outdoor moments even more memorable
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire frames fumes sorry you
can sit back relax and actually enjoy
the fire there's nothing like a roaring
fire to bring you back to what matters
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit and create story worthy moments
without the fireside fumes stainless
steel construction designed to regulate
airflow and burn more efficiently so
little smoke you'll wonder how there's
so much fire easy to light with a few
bits of starter your fire is blazing in
minutes there's
they're so confident you'll love it they
offer a lifetime warranty and a 30-day
free return policy right now you can get
big discounts on all fire pits during
solo stove summer sale and use promo
code bur at solostove.com for an extra
10 off that's solostove.com promo code
bur for ten dollars off on their top
on top of their incredible summer sale
discounts but hurry this sum the summer
sale ends
june
23rd oh look who it is everybody lastly
but not leastly
it's indochito
you probably need a suit exclamation
point
whether you're going to be a groom
in a wedding party or a lucky guest
everyone wants to look their best for a
wedding with the custom fitted suit from
indochino you'll look great feel
confident and enjoy the big day without
fussing over your clothes choose every
detail on a suit shirt dinner jacket and
more at affordable prices that may
surprise you for fully customized pieces
uh i didn't say that right and more at
affordable prices that may surprise you
for fully custom pieces every suit is
made to your exact measurements
and you can customize every detail
create a suit that fits you and your
style perfectly with options for fabrics
lapel shape custom monograms statement
linings and more the best part indochino
suits start from just 429 and shirts
some 79 dollars explore their relaxed
yet refined refined approach to spring
suits with their new spring pastels
perfect for a brunch or an easter
celebration uh if you've got a big day
coming up getting the perfect look is no
big deal with indochino get 50 off any
purchase at 3.99 or more by using promo
code bird indochino.com
that's 50 off a purchase of 3.99 or more
at i n d
o c h i n o dot com
promo code burr
all right well there you have it
um let's get into some of the questions
here for from the week all right from
the czech republic
uh
well what do you know the czech republic
i had a great time i was actually
talking about that tour
and how much fun i had
and i was talking about going budapest
in vienna and prague and all of these
places warsaw
and someone was saying like
you spoke english there right it's just
that's the funny [ __ ] ever
it's like yeah what do you think i
learned all those [ __ ] languages
yeah i like
i flunked french like every year in high
school like i that was one language
um no i didn't i spoke english and those
people
can speak english it's amazing and they
actually understand humor and all of
that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] incredible and uh
all of those places really stood out to
me that had really fun crowds and like
budapest and the room that i was in i
was like i would literally [ __ ] shoot
a special here
um and when i was in prague it was just
like
i was trying to see as much of it as i
possibly was driving around in cabs
looking at it all day
before my show or half day because we
had to travel there so i was like i've
been there but i don't really remember
much of it because i was gone within 24
hours anyway from the czech republic to
mr bill just saw paper tiger on netflix
and the czech republic how insane is
that
we're about three years behind sorry i
don't have a twitter account could never
figure out how to use it i love this
person you sound like me
so if this reaches you great if not no
biggie right you are an excellent
comedian
i love stand up as an art form
please don't stop i have no intentions
of stopping
um
but thank you for uh watching it that's
really cool
all right more
nerd
hate
dear billy brake bad uh i'd like to pile
on the hate for powerful nerds
uh bill gates is an [ __ ] who spends
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
on publicity to keep himself in good
graces i work for a tech yeah because
they're always saying like what a
philanthropist he is
i work for a tech company and anytime an
evp executive vice president
who comes from a tech background
is way more of a lizard brain than the
business school
background guy
what
i work for a tech company and anytime an
executive vice president who comes from
a tech background is way more of a
a lizard brain than the business school
background guy
all right i think
you missed a word or is there something
going on there i don't know for example
business school evp guy or gal will do
everything he can to make profits by
making shrewd business deals the tech
evp guy or gal would do everything he
can to push
programming narratives
as in human beings are programs that
they can control through additive habits
i.e social media well are they wrong
uh not saying one is better than the
other both of them talk about people
like ants
but it's way more unsettling coming from
the tech guy for some reason
yeah i understand that because i feel
like the business guy is the evil you're
used to where these guys are like
you know tech people and chemist i mean
they're like [ __ ] with the dna of
animals and our food supply and plants
and all that [ __ ] anyway this one tech
guy i have in mind
as i'm saying all of this would talk
about them as in everyone who didn't
work at our company and i'd be thinking
like yo man you're talking about
everyone here
like they don't have friends and family
in a conscious
conscience sorry
and like we wouldn't
want them programmed against their will
well just out of curiosity why don't you
say that
why don't you say these things in these
meetings
anyways this same guy would talk about
how pliable the public is all the time
their attention their opinions
everything yeah this guy's speaking my
language this is why i think
everything's [ __ ] rigged
then one day a co-worker showed me a
video of a former cia officer talking
about how pliable the public is
it was hard to shake that one off so we
both left work early that day to get
high and see a movie yep
that's j edgar hoover and then when they
actually discover the truth it's so
overwhelming they can't handle it
you go out and get high and you go watch
your movie also you called this like
eight years ago in one of your specials
i think or podcast how nerds will make
all the crazy weapons anyways yeah no
that's what it is
that's what it is
the donald trump sociopaths are nothing
without nerds making their psycho dreams
come true
you know old butterball whatever the
[ __ ] guy name is that we have
president now
yeah those guys without nerds they can't
get anything done
um
national donut day
dear billy butternut
i cannot remember the last time i had a
[ __ ] donut i'm actually proud of that
my fat office celebrated national donut
day but guess what
they made it a week-long thing and had
donuts every day from different places
around the city why not right all week
these pop portly bastards just chomped
up donuts disgusting all of them are
short of breath most of the time but
this week they were sucking air like the
atmosphere was collapsing
don't get me wrong i ate at least a
dozen myself but i'm in good shape i
played soccer in college and still do on
the weekends here's the kicker hey no
pun intended when it was national
fitness day or whatever it was called
they opened the windows and told people
they could take calls outside as if
fresh air somehow equated to exercise
jesus christ loved the podcast just got
the any into anything better loving that
too go [ __ ] yourself
sorry i had to take a sip of water there
um
yeah that's insane where where exactly
is that i actually watch this you know
my wife likes to watch the murder shows
like that snl sketch at night and she
had one on
and um i don't know what part of the
world
it was
but these were just the weirdest looking
[ __ ] people
just the weirdest collection
of people
where they they just looked very unique
um
in their weirdness they were just odd
looking people
and then there was one woman who was
kind of pretty
but like smoking hot for that area
but she you know she'd still be a seven
in like new york or something
but i mean she just must have been like
off the charts but i was just looking i
was going what is going on with these
people
their eyes were a little too far apart
their foreheads were like big and
sloping
and uh
you know the clothes i'm not gonna get
after you about the clothes are like you
know let's just
you don't have money
what are you gonna do right
you can't get on somebody like that but
that they look like they
grew up next to something where if where
a company
put something in the soil or in the
water supply
it's unreal how they get away with that
and then all of a sudden you got all
these [ __ ]
weird people just walking around looking
weird and killing each other
and then you just use it as like you
exploit it and sell advertising telling
their stories as if you care about these
stories
um
you know what happens in all those
murder things my wife falls asleep
halfway through it and i end up watching
the whole thing
um rude mom advice
uh dear billy wet t-shirt by the way
this this
one that i watched
was about this woman
you know who got killed by her
ex-husband right
and um
one of the things she did for exercise
was
you know she went to like this dance
class
it was great she lost all this weight
but i was just thinking like you know
think about this all the time with like
women like you should just instead of
taking a [ __ ] dance class like take
jujitsu like learn how to [ __ ] defend
yourself
so if some piece of [ __ ] guy comes at
you at the end of the [ __ ] day you
know most people i don't think knows
self-defense myself included
you know so like i don't care what size
a woman is she's a hundred [ __ ]
pounds i mean i wouldn't want a hundred
pound weight dropped on my foot um
so if you know how to throw a punch or a
kick i think you could [ __ ] in the
element of surprise they don't know
um i always just wonder why on all of
those shows they never like say that to
women to like you know hey why don't you
take some self-defense glasses
so you know what to do in these
situations so these [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ]
they probably don't do that because then
they would have nothing
they'd be killing they'd be biting the
hand that feeds
i'll tell you it's a sick world
entertainment um all right rude mom
advice dear billy wet t-shirt uh he
wouldn't want to see that
i need advice about my mother a couple
years ago while visiting my husband and
me
my mother made a comment
to my husband out of the blue that she
doesn't want her money mixing
with my husband's money after she dies
oh god
it's really [ __ ] amazing how stupid
people are that far into their life
in other words she only wants me to have
it or something like that my husband
didn't say anything at the time but
later told me
after she left that she's not welcomed
in the house
anymore due to her rudeness
honestly he couldn't care less about
money it's not a lot of money he just
didn't like her making that rude comment
well i can say as an older person he
should just laugh it off
you know you don't want to ban your
wife's
mom from coming into the [ __ ] house
you just have to accept the fact that
that's her mom and her your wife has
unconditional love for her so
you just you just end up
rather than resenting them showing up
you you turn it into joy
by you know if they think you're dumb
act dumber
you know if you find something that
[ __ ] annoys them like i got a buddy
of mine
he figured out his mother-in-law is a
narcissist
or a person that he works with was a
narcissist
and it used to really bother him but now
what he does is
he tells stories where he complements
over the top compliments
other people that that narcissist knows
and he said it drives her [ __ ] nuts i
mean that's what you want to do
um anyway my mother has always been a
rude person has made snide comments such
as this to other family members for as
long as i can remember i feel that she's
always been able to get away with the
bad
behavior since had
what with her bad behavior since
something has a history of gaslighting
people plus she's really good looking so
i think that makes people forgive her
more easily well why don't you tell her
to shut up
anyway i guess i need to talk to her
about this eventually but i'm not sure
how to approach it
how to approach her about it
i've successfully delayed her from
visiting for the past two years due to
covet but i'm running out of town time
she's an intimidating person
plus banning parents from the household
is a big no-no in chinese culture
mom's chinese-american my dad's white uh
they are divorced
oh okay well what does this have to do
with you
what's the divorce thing have to do with
anything plus spending house is a big
no-no in chinese culture
oh yeah well yeah don't do that you
don't don't i don't banner from the
house but
i think your husband's banning her from
the house because you're not saying
anything
um
or you married someone like your mother
now you're stuck in between the two of
them
um
any advice you were the lovely nia would
be greatly appreciated love your podcast
and my husband and i plan on attending
one of your shows in the near future
thanks and go hug yourself look at you
you got a nice heart um
what are you what are you afraid that
your mother's gonna do
just take her aside and just say you
know don't talk to my husband like that
what's she gonna do
you know
get mad
who gives a get mad i don't give a [ __ ]
what are you mad about
i didn't don't get mad at me i didn't do
anything don't say rude [ __ ] to my
husband you're welcomed over here but
you're not welcomed over here saying
rude [ __ ] to my husband if you say
something i'm gonna call you on it all
right that's it
stop being an [ __ ] just because
you're good-looking
all right get over yourself
you had your time
no one gives a [ __ ] about your money
don't say that because then she won't
give you your money
[Laughter]
yeah i i
i got beyonce one of the main reasons
the world is so [ __ ] up is people
don't say anything
and these [ __ ] abusive [ __ ] just
continue to just sort of do what it is
that they're doing
um
and nobody says anything that's like all
of this [ __ ] since
since uh all these this woke [ __ ]
movement like how [ __ ] sideways
this whole thing has gone
and how people
used the fact
that innocent people were like sexually
assaulted as a way to to
get their [ __ ] agenda that has
nothing to do with any of that
you know in through the door to rush
through the door like that [ __ ] always
happens
like after like 9 11 the government like
used that to just invade everybody's
[ __ ] privacy under the [ __ ]
umbrella of fighting terrorism
and they really just wanted to spy on
their own goddamn people oh billy you
gonna go down this road no i am not
um so
hey here's something i haven't talked
about in a while how about hockey what
the [ __ ] going on in hockey how about
those new york rangers
[ __ ] overachievers they were up one
game to none what's going on in that
series i have no idea
then it's edmonton colorado i've heard
that series
is crazy now hockey i like that sport
you know but hockey has not been without
its problems like when i was growing up
uh the favoritism that the [ __ ]
montreal canadiens the intimidation
factor that they had on the refs was
was just it was literally part of the
game there was like an unwritten rule
that if the canadians were losing
with seven minutes left you just as a
ref had to put them on the power play
um
it was a real weird thing but now no one
gives a [ __ ] about the canadians um
and i think it's a pretty goddamn i
think it's a good goddamn league i do
although a couple years ago i didn't
right now i do i don't know what to tell
you all right my brain is [ __ ]
is filled up with [ __ ] i have to do
tomorrow i know these podcasts have been
a little shorter lately but i'm i'm
sparing you
by doing that because i don't have much
of a life right now
i wake up i go to the gym and then i
[ __ ] go into an edit room and i just
stay in there and this
i think there's a window i've never
looked out
is there a window i don't even know i
just stay in there for like [ __ ]
you know whatever as long as i can seven
hours maybe after seven hours you're
just like all right [ __ ] this i have to
get out of here and then i come out
i get my car i practice my french
and i ride home
and then uh
then i play with my kids and i have like
the best [ __ ] like 90 minutes
now it's like two hours because my son
goes to bed a little bit later
um we got one of those little uh
portable bouncy houses
it's like the greatest [ __ ] thing
ever
you just plug it in
thing [ __ ] inflates in like 10
seconds
your kids go in there they go nuts they
have a great [ __ ] time
and you you get like at least seven or
eight minutes where they're so excited
to be in the bouncy house they don't
want you to go in there and you can
actually just chill
and have eight minutes sort it to
yourself while you're constantly
scanning the sky for birds of prey so
they don't come down and take your kids
if you're like me
you know you're constantly checking your
backyard to make sure coyote didn't jump
but i always think about that [ __ ]
dingo took me baby like i always think
about that [ __ ] wild animals and [ __ ]
you know so um
anyway
yeah the big thing is they i'm always
wearing a hat and they steal my hat and
then you know they want me to go [ __ ]
run after and get it
and the [ __ ] joy that they have
of me chasing them around we just laugh
our asses off
the whole time it's just it's the
[ __ ] best um
i really do realize i am an absolute
pushover as a parent though
i got to get a little better at that but
i am a [ __ ]
pushover
my daughter would be like can i stay up
and watch a movie and i'll be like no no
you got school tomorrow and she just
goes no
then i go all right
that's all the fight i have in me
and uh
my son just like
oh my god
he has the biggest tears when he cries
if so if i go to leave
you know i'm starting i'm going to start
doing my shows after my daughter goes to
bed because she gets so upset when i
leave at night and i go i'm coming right
coming back home
you know
and uh
that doesn't seem to like do the trick
and just have like massive amounts of
[ __ ] guilt as you're going to leave
so this is why i don't give a [ __ ] about
the nba finals i'm not going to get
like this level of upset
when i got two little ones that need me
like to that level
so um
but anyway this week is my birthday week
so boo doo doo
so i'm gonna be just [ __ ]
i think home all week
you know obviously editing and then just
[ __ ] home all week what am i even
talking about right now i'm just trying
to work out my [ __ ] week talking to
you guys all right that's the podcast
um
i don't know go [ __ ] yourselves enjoy
the nba finals this looks like it's
gonna go [ __ ] seven excruciating ones
uh have fun dying a thousand deaths i
think i'm good on it
uh that's what i say and then this game
starts and i still watch but as of right
now i think i'm done
i just can't
i can't handle it i just don't have it
in me you know
i'm like maverick and top gun right as a
fan
i just i can't [ __ ] do it anymore i
lost my edge and there's gonna be no
sequel he's not coming back
he's out he's taking his pension
we need someone else to take his place
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll check in on you on thursday